one
and you're live chairman
thank you berna good evening and welcome
to this southeast area planning
committee meeting on wednesday the 14th
of april 2021 my name is councilman nick
skeens and i'm the chair for this
committee
before we commence the business of the
meeting can i ask all in attendance to
observe a minute silence
to mark the passing of his highness
the duke of edinburgh
thank you everybody
you may hear from time time in the
background the horns of the wednesday
night racing starting in burnham i hope
it doesn't disturb anybody
members this meeting is held under new
regulations which came into effect on
the 4th of april
2020 in response to the covet 19
situation
please can i ask everyone present in
this meeting to ensure that your camera
remains on where broadband permits and
your microphone remains muted when not
addressing the committee this will
reduce background noises and avoid any
unintentional disturbances we are
streaming this meeting live as well as
recording and by being present in the
meeting you are giving your consent to
being recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the hands up function of the
meeting to indicate if you wish to speak
you are reminded that apart from
indicating points of order uh that uh or
that you
have to leave the meeting the chat
function should not be used for
questions or any other purpose
when speaking and referring to agenda
papers please ensure you reference a
page or paragraph number and keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible and when invited to speak
please ensure you turn on your
microphone it is of course so easy to
forget and now if i may ask officers
taking part in the meeting to introduce
themselves starting with hannah dungate
good evening councillors hannah dungate
planning specialist in development
management thank you
thank you matt lee
good evening members i'm matt lee lead
specialist place and chief plan officer
here at morton district council thank
you
thank you michael johnson
good evening chair members my name is
michael johnson lead specialist
development management thank you
uh and bernie casey
good evening members ben casey clark to
this evening's committee thank you
thank you are there any other officers
present
no chair okay thank you well before i
call on the club to take the roll call
of committee members can i ask those
councillors in attendance are you not
members of the committee to introduce
themselves please
please let the record show that
councillor morris is lurking
thank you very much councillor morris
uh berna please can you now carry out a
roll call of members to confirm who's in
attendance
thank you chairman members i will call
your names in alphabetical order please
indicate that you're in attendance
starting with councillor bassinger
good evening and i'm present thank you
thank you counselor beal
castell
caster bell
i'm president good evening everybody
thank you council channel good evening
everybody um i'm present thank you
pastor helm
president good evening everybody
thank you castle hull
president bernard good evening everybody
as well
thank you casler skins
yes i'm definitely here
thank you stamp
present burner thank you
thank you chairman
thank you very much indeed uh berna
please members be advised that we have
two public participants in the meeting
this evening i will call on them to
speak at the appropriate time please
note that
these people are going to be in the
meeting
and their microphones and cameras will
be off until decisions are made on their
particular agenda items uh apologies for
absence may i have any apologies for
absence please berna
and yes chairman we've received
apologies for absence from councillors
uh duik and boyce thank you thank you
very much indeed uh item three minutes
from the 17th of march 2021 it's
recommended that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 17th of march 2021
founded on pay found on pages 7 to 20
are approved as a true and accurate
record i so move if you wish to second
that motion motion could you unmute well
mr chairman thank you
if any member wishes to raise any matter
of accuracy please use the hands up
function to indicate and i will invite
you to speak
okay i can't see any hands up so
i guess bernie you can't see anybody
either no chairman okay so uh are we
happy to agree this by ascent members
i agree
great
okay we've agreed that by a cent thank
you very much
uh now on to declarations of interest
item before to disclose the existence
and nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regards to paragraph six to eight
including inclusive of the code of
conduct to members members are reminded
that they are also required to disclose
any such interests as soon as they
become aware should the need arise
throughout the meeting
so if any member has an interest to
declare please use the hands up function
to
indicate this and i'll invite you to
speak i'm going to start
in item 5 i need to declare an interest
which i believe is non-pecuniary but
insofar as someone connected to the
applicants has recently provided
assistance to a local charity of which i
am a trustee so it could be in the
public mind seen as a motivation for me
to look favorably upon that application
uh to avoid any possibility of doubt i'm
not going to take part in the debate and
i'm not going to vote and when it comes
to the item i'm going to hand over the
chair to the vice chair councillor bell
in case a split vote requires a casting
vote uh so that's me declaring my uh
interest on item five berna are there
any other members indicating a wish to
speak
yes german caster channel
thank you council channel uh thank you
chairman uh my normal one um in that i
must declare non-pecuniary interests i'm
also a member of essex county council
which of course is consulted on matters
that's under its remit such as highways
access
um education or anything like that
chairman um that madonna will be done
through the planning application
consultation stage thank you
thank you councillor chana uh councillor
helm
thank you mr chairman
six pecuniary interests and the
applicant has repaired my washing
machine several times and i can't feel i
cannot take part thank you
thank you very much are you planning to
leave the meeting at that point
i'll be leaving
thank you very much
okay we now go on to item five twenty
one zero zero zero eight eight stroke
full burnham yacht harbour foundry lane
burnham on crouch and it's at this point
that i'm going to hand the meeting over
to councillor uh vanessa bell and i will
take no part in this item
thank you can i ask if cancer and cancer
ham could lower their hands that's
lovely thank you
thank you um councillor skins so we
moved to agenda item 5 found on pages
21-34 please note that a member's update
in relation to this application has been
circulated prior to the meeting
in a moment i will call on the officer
to present this item remember as a
reminder that if you wish to speak on
this item please make this known by
using the hands up function within this
meeting i will then come to you in turn
please keep your points clear and
succinct
so ms dungate over to you if you could
present the report for us please
yes of course thank you chairman
i'll just share my screen
okay
thank you planning permission is sought
for the temporary stationing of a single
mobile home
for security staff accommodation at the
burnham yacht harbour for a period of 18
months
the applicant is seeking to re
regularize the sighting of the mobile
home which is already stationed at the
site and has been the subject of an
enforcement investigation since june
2020
this application follows a previously
refused application for two mobile homes
at the site also to be used for staff
accommodation
and the previous application was refused
on the basis that insufficient
information had been received to justify
the essential need for the workers
accommodation in this location
as well as the fact that the mobile
homes are sited within the middle of the
working storage yard
at the burnham yacht harbour which would
mean that no usable private amenities
space could be provided at the site
um as you've already mentioned
chairman a member's update update has
been circulated which includes details
of the additional public comments
received
here is the location plan for the site
the application site area which is
outlined in red is the storage yard
behind the existing yacht harbour
buildings where the mobile homes are
currently situated
the blue line indicates the extent of
the yacht harbour which is also in the
applicant's ownership
and it should be noted that the
application site is located outside of
the defined settlement of burnham on
crouch so is within the countryside in
planning policy terms
this is the block plan for the proposal
which shows the positioning of the
mobile home on the northern edge of the
site within the storage yard
and these are the elevations of the
existing buildings at the site um not
showing where the caravans are situated
[Music]
these are the elevations showing the
mobile home in situ at the site which
you can see here and here
and these are further elevations showing
the caravan in situ at the site
at caravan mobile home i should say
this is the floor plan of the mobile
home
showing
two bedrooms and
living and kitchen areas
with the potential to accommodate up to
six people
this is a photograph taken from foundry
lane looking towards the car park and
the yacht harbour in the distance the
application site is located just behind
the trees on the right hand side of the
picture
and this is another photograph facing
the application site taken from the car
park
it also shows the track located at the
rear of the site
this is a photograph taken from the
track located at the rear of the site
and as you can see from this photograph
the mobile homes as well as a number of
storage containers
and working machinery are located in the
storage yard
this is another photograph
also taken from the track
this is a photo from foundry lane
looking into the site and as you can see
through the trees um the mobile home is
there
and this is a photograph of the existing
buildings taken from the front of the
harbour
to the side of the buildings you can see
the mobile homes
located within the storage yard through
the gap
and this is a photograph of the mobile
homes taken by the applicant within the
sites
and you'll note that there is a mobile
home here covered in tarpaulin
that was included within the previous
refused application but um it is no
longer included within this application
and the applicant has advised that this
is going to be removed on the 20th of
april so next week
and just for reference this is an aerial
photograph of the site just to better
show the location of the mobile homes
within the storage yard
so to conclude as explained in the
committee report the proposal has been
assessed um largely against policy h7 of
the malden local development plan
which has been designed to assess
essential workers accommodation in the
countryside
as the proposal relates to temporary
workers accommodation for a business
outside of the defined settlement
boundary it is considered that this
policy is relevant to the current
proposal
policy h7 states that permanent or
temporary accommodation in the
countryside where it relates to a rural
business or enterprise will only be
permitted when a number of criteria have
been met
to summarize the criteria include
evidence to be submitted to the
satisfaction of the council that there
is a functional need for a full-time
worker in this location
that there are no suitable alternative
dwellings available in the area to serve
the identified need
and the size of the structure is
commensurate with the needs of the
enterprise concerned
the development should also be designed
to minimize the adverse impact upon the
character and appearance of the
area as noted in section 5.1 of the
committee report and in particular
paragraphs 5.1.8
to 5.1.14
due to the evidence submitted it is not
considered that there is an essential
need for a security staff member to
reside on site
nor has it been demonstrated that the
mobile home would be commensurate to the
needs of the business concerned given
that it could accommodate up to six
people
no evidence have been submitted to
demonstrate that there are no other
suitable alternative dwellings available
in the wider area
and it is felt that the position of the
mobile home would increase the amount of
structures at the site which would be
inappropriate and harmful to the
character and appearance of the area
although it is acknowledged that the
proposal would be on a temporary basis
for 18 months
it is noted that no private amenity
space would be provided for the
occupiers of the mobile home given that
it's positioned in the middle of a
working storage yard
um and for these reasons the application
is recommended for refusal
thank you chairman
you should cancel pal
i do apologize members uh officers
members of the public i was uh
muted
so we do have one public participant for
this planning application in line with
the public participation scheme i now
invite the applicant mr lingard to read
out his submission
may i remind you that you are allocated
two minutes only for public speaking in
accordance with the scheme and please
turn your camera and microphone off when
finished speaking
thank you mr lingard
hello can you see me yes
okay fine when does my team
just now okay thank you hello my name is
richard lingard i'm a director of
burnham marina and have been for over 15
years during my time in charge we've had
no problems in modern district council
until the advent of the covered epidemic
explaining how marina works in two
minutes is very difficult but here goes
the caravan in question was brought in
during the first lockdown the reasoning
behind this is very simple the marina
contains 350 leisure and commercial
boats is both a major employer and
tourist attraction in burnham and is a
very large piece of infrastructure
within the marina are two rnli lifeboats
and two crouch authority boats that need
access 24 7. we also have people staying
on board their vessels because they are
vulnerable and don't want to risk
catching code from their families at
home and conversely frontline workers
staying on their boats whilst they work
because they don't want to go home and
risk infecting their parents or
grandparents
before covered we had harbour masters
working from nine in the morning to five
in the afternoon and then staff in our
solitaire restaurant from five to
midnight and then a third-party security
firm from midnight to eight or providing
emergency cover and help if needed the
harbour masters are all aged between 60
and 75 and since the first lockdown they
will not come in if a third-party
security firm has been sharing their
facilities in harbor office overnight
and under kobe guidance to swallow our
restaurant has been closed this means we
only had cover from nine to five not
good if there is for example a hydraulic
gate failure a power cut oil spill or
emergency services need a site layout to
locate somebody so we arranged for
caravan and a member of staff to move in
during the epidemic and to provide cover
this is absolutely a temporary
application and we would undertake to
remove the caravan after 12 to 18 months
and further degree it would just be for
one person and they would have to be an
employee of the marina
we know how to run a marina as does the
rnli and the crouch harbor authority
hence their support for this application
the town council has supported this and
i don't believe there are any objections
although that might change we can't run
a business like this by working from
home it's been hard time and even now
only half of our facilities are open we
would appreciate your support over what
is a strange time and i can't emphasize
enough this is just the temporary code
of measure
i'm sorry that was a bit quick i had to
put it into two minutes
sorry no thank you
there we go thank you my camera off for
yes please mr legard if you would
yes please
thank you
thank you very much so um
members i now open the debate and invite
you to put any questions or make any
comments you have on the report berna
has anyone indicated that they wish to
speak
i can't see any hands
no chairman not at the moment councillor
hall
and for and then cancer helm council
hell i'll come to you i'm cancer stamp
so cancer hull
well thank you very much um i i do uh
having running a small business myself
on the same idea
it is important that you have people
there so i'd be if it's only temporary
um in support of it
thank you
thank you councillor hull councillor
helm
thank you madam chairman um
have we got any pictures of the actual
yacht harbour or youngster in the
harbour
um mustang gait do we have
um no i didn't actually take a picture
of the harbour although i can see it in
my mind's eye apologies if i may carry
on medal chairman please do councillor
helm thank you mr anger millions of
pounds worth of equipment and everything
on these boats
it's ridiculous that they can't have a
security person on site
to protect
this valuable asset or these valuable
assets
um
we're saying it's outside defined
barrier
boundaries and someone should have a
house within the town or whatever
how can they monitor the site if they're
living off the site
um if the police get cold that'll be 20
minutes before they get there and all
the twos and blues will be going and all
the things will be gone by the time they
get there so it's in my mind it's
essential
security person on site
on the top thank you very much madam
chairman thank you cancer helm
councillor stamp
um yes thank you madam chair
members
um i have great sympathy um uh with the
applicant
um
i think councillor helm has just made an
excellent point um
actually i should have declared an
interest sorry members we do actually
put a little boat in there so
i will declare an interest actually on
there um oh crikey yes because it's not
in the river at the moment but we do
actually have a boat in there um i don't
think that's clusters pecuniary
that's the decision is yours
well no
how do you wish to proceed on this i
think
oh goodness i think because i do have a
boat and i pay in there it's classed as
having a pecuniary interest
so i'm afraid
i can't speak on it other than to say
what i've said so i'm afraid i'm going
to have to bow out i do apologize and my
mistake members because i don't class it
as my boat it's my husband's and yet
again we have the same thing
because i'm married to him i have to
declare it anyway thank you i do
apologize
thank you very much you have to leave
the meeting councillor stamp yeah i will
funerally you have to leave yeah
i'm going to go hang on i'm just going
to put my hand down
i just saw you sorry i just saw you
sitting there and i thought you know
when you said black you know
vernon will exclude me bernie will
execute cancel the stamp is not faster
than the speed of light on the computer
so we'll just pull this
thank you very much um berna members
does any do anybody does anybody else
wish to speak
on this item
counselor helm you still have your hand
up is that legacy
you're muted
madame chairman might speak yesterday
we go against the officer's
recommendation and prove this
um do i have a secondary for that motion
counselor how are you seconding
you are muted cancer hull
sorry i'll second it
thank you councillors
um
so
but um
listen to me
sorry bernard i can see mr lee
yes mr lee i'm sure is probably going to
say the same thing as i i'm going to say
i think
or does he want to speak to this sorry
before i mention about reasons for
approval
well obviously yeah normally i get an
opportunity to come back after the
debate to
highlight any policy conflicts or
anything is that okay chairman yes of
course it is mr lou of course it is
please go ahead thank you members um
you know as an authority obviously we
are sympathetic to the need for
businesses but we do need to be
conscious of
our policies and also previous decisions
that the council has made um
the argument put forward in relation to
a need for security obviously something
that is very common across the district
especially in such a rural
area such as malden and it's something
that generally is not authority we do
resist unless there is specific evidence
of a particular need and that's both
even been historically both temporary
and permanent and this is something that
generally
i'm not going to say always because i
might be wrong but i can't remember in
my seven years i've been here thus
losing an appeal and i'm not sure if
other members might remember they've got
especially some of the members they've
got better memories than i have for such
matters but
it is something that generally you
should be looking to provide
other forms of security before allowing
a permanent residential property the
other thing obviously in relation to
this this is a somebody to stay there
overnight but as the
applicants i was about to say put up in
a hearing all day as the applicant
stated that you have external
third party that comes at night time to
actually do the security or covers it so
the actual caravan occupation although
it's for accommodation would actually be
primarily required through the day time
so obviously that's a slight
juxtaposition with the reasoning of why
there should be somebody on site
permanently in a residential
accommodation
in the form of a caravan and then the
need for it if you see what i mean
members that actually this
protection the security that the
applicant is requiring isn't for
unsociable hours this is actually for
sociable hours and therefore that adds
to the conflict with the policy and the
and my advice would be members to the
planning weight to be given because
there is an external company that
delivers the security and has done for
years successfully from what we gather
from what the applicant said before this
um
so i would be
conscious at the appellant or so the
applicant's really trying to solve an
issue in the daytime and i'm not
convinced professionally in my advice be
that a permanent somebody there 24 hours
is the way to solve an issue in the day
time when such a an approach is such in
conflict with our policies thank you
um thank you mr lee council held before
you come back um i'd just like to uh
i'm sure i heard mr lingard say that the
um
people who are living on the marina have
uh refused the
third party security company due to the
covert risk and the harbour masters also
have refused that so uh
i i'm not seeing from from what the
applicant said i'm i'm not seeing seeing
it in the same light mr lee as as you
and in that respect um
but thank you very much council helm
if you'd like to
sorry is it okay to ask does dungate
double check the documents submitted
because
um what actually was i wasn't stated by
the and we'll hope to be able to give
you a definitive stance on that if miss
duncan well the debate's going on if we
just ask her to quickly let that thank
you thank you very much mr lee that
would be helpful so councillor helm i'm
going to you
next i see mr lingard you have your hand
up but i cannot allow you to come back
unfortunately on that so uh apologies
counselor helm
thank you very much madam chairman it
was pointed out by the applicant
that uh the harvard masters wouldn't
come on the site while he had outside
security people coming on
and it was rather convenient to admit
the whole of the harbour the boats that
sit in the harbour to show why the
security is needed
i think that's presented one-sided
so i'll still go with my recommendation
please
thank you councillor helm councillor
bassinger thanks
thank you very much um i would just like
to say that obviously we're all aware
that we are hopefully coming out of
lockdown and i think the argument for
covid
um is is a little hard pushed really and
so i think we should we should take heed
that uh the case of the officers and not
so
quickly jump into this sort of cove
necessity because uh
you know that that really is not the
case i don't think anymore
um without wishing to get into a debate
about the uh wires and wherefores and
whatevers have covered and lockdown i my
view is that we are far from out of the
woods yet and
precautionary measures should be taken
and could we not possibly condition that
in some way
i'm wondering so that if uh when we do
reach for lockdown for longer than a
period of a certain amount of time then
then the caravan's removed i'm not sure
i'd
i would rather we condition in that way
because i think we it would be very
premature to suggest that kovis is over
at this point
council passenger you'd like to come
back i would i don't think we should be
bringing covid into a into a planning
argument really i don't i just don't see
why we're doing that you know we are
coming out of covid and to be honest you
know
as much as we all sort of
just dragging our heels we do need to
come out and so i i don't see how we can
really factor this in
thank you councillor passenger mr lee
you are ready to come back please thank
you just in a point directly in relation
to the point you raised um
it would be difficult for us i think to
word a condition that would be robust
precise and forceful etc that was
flexible around government providence in
relation to covid or anything which is
covered which i think has officers
reports certainly would agree with uh
councillor bassinger in that it should
be given a limited way but irrespective
that if members did feel that there was
a concern
i may be tempted to encourage members to
look at given a lesser time
and caravan which is not the subject of
this application and is due to be
removed as an 18
so that would suggest that
a residential king
obviously we weren't made aware of that
until
2020 last year and we learned that the
second mobile home had
arrived at the site let me just clarify
on the 10th of april last year so
um
that's just what i wanted to add about
that if that's okay thank you very much
uh mr gate just before i go to you
councillor helm just a couple of things
um firstly
my understanding is that we do have to
look at the application that is before
us um
and not look at what has happened in the
past apologies if i'm yes i'd second it
chairman
thank you
so um members i believe we do uh have a
proposal on the table which is
to approve the application um but
subject to 12 months rather than 18
months is that correct
counselor help
correct madam chairman
um thank you so members do we uh do we
need to go to a vote on that or can we
agree by a sentence i'm sensing perhaps
a vote
would we like to go to vote members
chairman um you need to have reason for
approval before the uh
apologies mr lee so councillor helm i
believe you have some reasons for
approval
i'm not sure whether the policies cover
millions of pounds of equipment to
protect but that's why i want to protect
millions of pounds worth of equipment
boats and obviously everything else
thank you
i mean i do believe again i don't want
to get myself in deep water no pun
intended by uh revealing my knowledge of
the local development plan but uh
river-related employment uses i believe
its policies are point are one point
three and one point four i may be wrong
on that but we do say that we will
support
river-related employment and
but it's it's an important part of the
community it's an important asset to
burn them the yacht harbour and as
council helm said there are a lot of
very expensive boats in there
so um i think it does
meet those policy requirements would be
my comment
mr lee i don't know if that's sufficient
mr lee
sorry chairman i was just uh talking
without i'm muting um
what oh
i'll turn my camera on um
i obviously as a reason for approval
obviously i my ability to assist members
is much less than it is with a
reasonable proposal but um and i do
think council helms
wording was a little abrupt and lacking
maybe some policy bases but um i think
i can give some assistance if mr council
helm agreed with that what's saying is
that taking into account the exceptional
circumstances there is an additional
risk
that wouldn't normally be in place and
that's a material consideration that's
outweighing the conflict with the policy
i don't know if that's exactly what
council helm was not saying it's
optimistic to agree with that or not but
roughly that'd be my interpretation of
his statement
council of health for once uh mr lee i
entirely agree with you well done
thank you so i do believe we have um we
have a proposal on the table with
the relevant planning
reasons attached so um
berna i think we go to the vote do we
now
yes chairman
so members uh we're voting contrary to
the officer's recommendation to approve
the application for the reasons as
outlined by councillor helm
members i will take uh call you in
alphabetical order starting with
councillor bassinger can you please stay
clearly for against our abstain
against
that's the big council bell
for
chana
regrettably against
thank you members that's everybody
that's three for the um recommendation
to approve two against and no
abstentions
thank you very much i shall i'll meet
myself this time so
thank you
members and burner so i hand over head
back now to councillor schemes please
thank you very much can i just sorry
members can i just call back in
councillor stamp please
and can't and remove councillor health
yes please don't know i've just logged
on i've just oh lovely thank you very
much fun because i kept jumping in and
out burner so
joining and disappearing when you
weren't finished okay and i'm just going
to remove mr um
yes
good just realized we didn't do
conditions
okay well i'll have to hand this back to
uh councillor bell
apologies for that um mr lee so
conditions uh
uh off the ones i would consider
obviously as its respect we don't need
time we'd need plans um
we would need
added sorry i can see cancer stamp in
the corner
the easiest thing might be just to
delegate to officers
can we delegate
yes
please yes we'll delegate to officers mr
lee
with agreement with yourself check we'll
confirm that great that'd be the easiest
thank you very much for that
thank you oh what a kerfuffle back to
you councillor schoons thank you very
much
council
uh uh berna you're saying something i'm
just wondering uh here's cancer stamp
okay lovely thank you very much we're
ready to go
wonderful yes it's all uh musical chairs
here uh today um uh we're going on to
item six now that's 21 strokes 0 0 1 0 1
stroke full land adjacent hipsies
cottage the street
steeple
uh in a moment i'm going to call on the
officer to present this item uh and
members i remind you about the uh
putting your hands up and speaking
succinctly uh so uh miss dungate could
you please present the report
yes thank you chairman
planning permission is sought for the
construction of a new
two-bedroom dwelling house at the land
adjacent to hipsey's cottage the street
which is within the defined settlement
boundary of steeple
steeple is classified as a smaller
village within the district which has
few or no services and facilities and
limited or no access to public transport
as the council cannot currently
demonstrate a five-year housing land
supply the tilted balance is engaged and
it is necessary to assess whether the
proposed development is sustainable
steeple is located in a remote position
within the countryside away from any
nearby services or facilities and is not
considered to be easily accessible by
foot or public transport
although the property would contribute
to the identified need for smaller
houses within the district the addition
of one property within an unsustainable
location would weigh against the
proposal which would have limited
benefit in making up the current housing
land supply shortfall
the application site is adjacent to
hipsey's cottage which is a grade two
listed building which forms part of a
cluster of
grade two listed buildings on both sides
of the street here
these properties have value as a group
in the immediate vicinity of the
application site
and it should be noted that the
conservation officer has subjected to
the proposal on the basis that it would
cause minor harm to the significance of
the adjacent heritage asset hipsis
cottage
this is noted at paragraphs 5.3.12
to 5.3 14 of the committee report
also located to the east of the
application site are detached bungalows
here
which are set back from the road and
have parking areas to the front
these properties all sit within fairly
medium-sized plots
here is the existing block plan for the
proposal
this plan shows the existing garage out
building within the plot as well as the
driveway and parking area
associated with hipsies cottage as well
as the residential garden to the rear
here is the proposed block plan as you
can see oh sorry the proposed house
would be set back within the site in
line with this existing bungalow east of
the site
a shared driveway area would be located
in front of the new house with a tandem
parking arrangement serving both
properties
as a result of the narrow plot size the
proposed property is considered to be a
cramped and contrived form of
development which would appear to have
been forced into a small wedge of
amenities space in this location
as such the proposal is considered to
have a harmful impact on the character
and appearance of the area which is
assessed in paragraphs 5.3.9 to
5.3.11 of the committee report
it should also be noted as a result of
this layout
that the highways authority have
objected to the
proposal as there would not be a the
provision of a turning area as a result
of the result of the contrived form of
development
as well as insufficient visibility
displays due to the location of the
proximity of the access to the
neighbouring property here
this would lead to vehicles reversing
with restricted visibility onto the busy
carriageway of the street to the
detriment of the safety of all highway
users
these are the existing elevations of
this part of the street scene
and these are the proposed elevations
showing um
the proposed property adjacent to
hipsies cottage as well as the
neighboring bungalow
when viewed in isolation there are no
objections to the design of the house
which would be similar in scale form and
materials to hipsies cottage
these are the existing side elevations
of hipsies cottage in the context of the
neighbouring bungalow and although it is
not shown here the proposed property
would be located roughly here
in line with
the existing bungalow
these are the proposed side elevations
of the cottage
and as you can see they they don't show
the property in relation to the
neighboring properties
this is the proposed ground floor plan
of the news new house
which better shows the setback location
of the property
and these are the proposed first floor
plans showing two bedrooms at first for
level there are also no side windows
serving the first floor
this photograph is taken from the street
looking east towards hipsie's cottage
which is here
and the application site which is next
to hipster's cottage
and all of these properties are listed
this is a photograph of the application
site
at the point where the new house is
proposed there is a noticeable change in
character within the street scene from a
small cluster of taller historic
buildings fronting the main road here
to contemporary bungalows which are
lower in height and are set back from
the main road here
this is a better photograph showing the
adjacent bungalow
this photograph shows a long-range view
towards the application site from the
street
as previously discussed given the
surrounding context and the proposed
positioning of the property towards the
rear of the site
at this location within the street scene
it is considered to
appear out of character with the the
surrounding area
this would be exacerbated by the setback
positioning of the neighboring bungalows
meaning that the proposed property would
appear as a prominent feature within the
street scene here
as the application um
for the reasons above surrey the
application is recommended for a refusal
due to the fact that the proposed
development would be disconnected and
isolated from services and facilities by
reason of his unsustainable location
and would provide poor quality and
limited access to public transportation
resulting in an increased need of
private vehicle ownership
the proposed development due to its
layout and design is also considered to
be a contrived form of development which
would result in significant harm to the
character and appearance of the area
as well as the neighbouring list of
building hipsies cottage
additionally the development would
detrimentally impact on highway safety
due to the lack of a turning area for
both properties as a result of the
contrived nature of the development as
well as the tandem parking arrangement
thank you chairman
thank you very much indeed mr dungate uh
now we have a public participant uh the
agent mr lonergan uh who's going to
speak on this planning application uh mr
lonergan can i remind you that you have
two minutes and two minutes only uh this
is uh for public speaking in accordance
with the scheme and please uh see you
have your camera on your microphone um
is on now too can you turn them both off
when you finish speaking
and if you would like now to uh go ahead
and we'll time you two minutes good
evening
the applicants have lived in the village
in hipsters cottage for over 20 years
and want to retire to the village
there is a district-wide shortage of two
bedroom dwellings and although for their
own use the two bed cottage proposed
does provide such accommodation
hence this application for a smaller
more easily maintained and adapted house
of a similar scale appearance and
materials to the listed dwelling they
currently live in
i'd note that there are no objections
from neighbours and the parish council
support the application
the office's issue with the dwelling
seems less to be about its appearance
more about its location on the plot
um
the conservation officer suggests
advised for attention with the listed
cottage but i see it differently the
current setting is a two-story
attractive listed cottage
with an prickly tin iron in concrete
garage
um and then the two-story brick 20th
century
the
bungalows the single story bungalows and
it's an odd
relationship
that proposed introduces an attractive
transition between the timber-clad
listed building
and the bungalows it improves the
setting
in my opinion
the other major issue seems to be access
for car parking the applicants currently
reverse into their yard through a narrow
entrance with very poor visibility as do
many residents on this stretch of the
street
so that's
arrangements being maintained it's not a
new arrangement
um
but this arrangement is being improved
because we're proposing to widen the
access
onto the street and improve visibility
by reducing the hedgerow that's
at the boundary and therefore access is
improved
um on those two reasons um i think the
application should be supported and
approved
thank you very much
thank you very
much lonergan i'm just going to refer to
somebody's telephone is ringing if they
could oh sorry that was the that was the
bell thank you
sorry of course very old-fashioned
telephone i have in my mind there but
anyway uh so
uh yes um uh miss dungate uh did i read
something somewhere about uh highways
objecting to this can you remind me why
they did
um yes of course i'll just find it in
the report if i may
um
it's section 5.5 relates to access
parking and highway safety where i
discuss the highways objection
they've objected to the scheme um on the
basis that
the first reason there isn't
a turning area proposed which would mean
that the cars would have to egress the
site
um
potentially reversing into the main road
and also because of insufficient
visibility displays um because of the
extension of the dropped curb and access
to the site closer to hipsies cottage
would mean that um cars
could potentially not
see oncoming traffic which would likely
lead to increased conflict and risk of
collisions for both emerging and
approaching vehicles
aside from that or in addition to that
this is creating an additional dwelling
at the site so although
there is an existing arrangement for
the existing occupiers of hipsies
cottage to
egress and access the site
this i'm not sure how long that
arrangement has been in place but this
would worsen the situation because we
have now have
the parking area for two properties not
just one um and
the the the amount of v vehicular
movements would increase as a result of
the tandem parking arrangement and
moving cars around within the site
without a turning area okay thank you
very much so in short um
uh there's a problem there already
as i think mr lonergan suggested uh and
that may be exacerbated by a new
property okay i'm opening this up for
general uh debate um uh i have seen uh
that uh councillor bell has her hand up
caslabel
thank you um mr chairman let me just
take it down now
um yes thank you uh
ms dungate for your report my
there used to be a thing now officers
will be able to help me out with this
i'm sure but there used to be a thing
called backland development and this was
very much frowned upon
um
i don't know if it is still the case but
my concerns are mainly
well highways how how rarely is it that
highways actually consider something
serious enough to object to
my experience is actually never i think
this is the first time i've heard the
highways object something which
suggests to me that it's a pretty
serious issue
but secondly with the
parking we have to consider this in
perpetuity now it may be that the
current um occupants if they're going to
occupy
the cottage have an arrangement to share
this parking space and this access with
the new occupants of hipsters cottage
however
that will not necessarily apply to
future occupants
so we are creating we are creating a
potential issue
with the shared parking space
now i i can't remember if that that is a
material planning consideration or not
again officers will be able to help me
out on that but um
for those reasons and for the objection
of the conservation officer
um i'm minded to support the officer's
recommendation thank you
thank you um uh uh mr lee have you got
anything to add to what um
uh councillor bell said just there yep
happy to assist members as best i can as
always um
the point about
backland development is something a
fairly interesting one um it is
something that's
i don't say frowned upon but obviously
when we're looking at applications we're
normally looking at things such as
character the area urban grain pattern
development so quite often
what is backland development is
unacceptable because it will conflict
with that other times it might be that
actually a piece of other development
could create its own quantum or it could
face onto a street so and therefore it
might be acceptable you might have
historic developments to a certain
extent this wouldn't be backland event
because it would still have a frontage
to um
a street um
so it wouldn't be the traditional form
of back then backland and what this
would fall into is if you consider it's
acceptable to certainly is um in-field
development where there would normally
be some sort of gap some sort of space
where it's considered appropriate to put
a property in and that's called in-field
development and
on various matters that can or can't be
acceptable and i think uh ms dungate's
report really covers that match to
certain thing except in highlights how
the design of the property on its own
per se isn't necessary the conflict it's
the other issues that go with it and
that is where the problems come um in
relation to the second query um
my brain has gone blank and i can't
remember what you asked
it was about the um the access the
shared access and shed
you're right um
planning has to look at the lifetime of
the development and
obviously one of the conflicts and the
concerns officers have in relation to
this application is the town development
its relationship to
creating a car parking space in front of
a dwelling that wouldn't be separate um
and as you said yourself just because an
applicant may have a relationship with
somebody whether it's quite often it may
we not say anyone per se but quite
frankly you hear applications whether
it's for a relative or something like
that and we go well that'll be fine well
actually members we have to look at the
lifetime of development and
having such a relationship for car
parking for two dwellings in front of
one is not something that generally we
would support because of the potential
conflicts and disturbance and everything
else so that's why the reason for
refusal
around that deals with that matter thank
you thank you very much indeed mr lee uh
councillor chana
thank you chairman
um
i found myself a bit confused with the
report and i wanted to ring the office
but i'm sorry i haven't been available
today
um it started off at the beginning of
the report talking about to the north
was undergrowth and um and what have you
and then it also said to the north also
was
a stretch of historic buildings
regarding the un uh regarding the
historic buildings did you mean to the
west really of the site can i just ask
that
also i do have some sympathies with this
application i i will say that
um because i know that it's been said
it's an unsustainable location and yes
of ldp i'm aware of what it says about
steeple
however regarding the sun and anchor
when that was considered
um i i can tell you the report that went
before the committee
um
said that the majority of the site the
iranka was just within the settlement
boundary and then quoted s1 and s8 and
then mentioned about being a small
village again
and went on about lack of public you
know the public transport and public
services however nevertheless the site
would be regarded as being within a
sustainable location
so
therefore this report is saying this is
unsustainable
location i think we need to be clear
with regarding steeple is it one or the
other
um i would like the um
let or the consultation response from
the uh conservation officer read out
because again maybe it's my
misinterpretation of the report
looking at 5.3
and it was the last part it says
it is the opinion of the council's
specialist heritage and conservation
officer i think the words missing here
that due to the minor harm posed by the
proposal
the development poses some conflict with
this duty and that duty is to give great
weight to conservation um
issues as detailed within that paragraph
so i took it that the conservation
officer saw there was minor harm
um to the listed building through this
development
and um i'm not i would like the air for
the conservations um officers uh
response read out if i may just to see
if my brains got it wrong or right i
think that might clear out because i
didn't read it as objection
um
regarding also the report it does say
that in isolation the design of the
of the application dwelling
um is actually in isolation there seems
to be no issue with that
and also um i do appreciate the issue of
perhaps the street scene
but there are some
mentions crammed in but if you look on
the other side of the road you'll see
or if you look actually the block plan
you'll see quite a few uh what i would
call crammed in um sites and bearing in
mind what happened at southeast
regarding st lawrence where i consider
the sun who was crammed in um and
everything but
recommended for approval and i'm not
having to go at the officers but to me
that was crammed in um you know i'm i'm
just saying i don't necessarily see this
as crammed in
however and i've probably forgotten a
number of things i wanted to say
the big issue and council of bells
referred to it and i have to say when
highways come up with something
i think we would be
our peril
to ignore
highways when they can cannot support an
application
because if we were to override that
then i think you know let's be frank if
anything
was to happen in the future
um
i i would not feel comfortable in that
so i take the highways objection as very
very sensible but i would like some
responses or some explanation regarding
the sustainable site bearing in mind the
sun and anchor have described and then
we get this also i'd like to hear the
conservation officers objection because
i didn't read it in the in the merits of
the report i'm afraid as objecting and
saw it as minor harm which really uh
caused the conflict with the duty of
what the government says about
protecting uh sort of conservation
issues so um but it's the highways area
for me i think being set back
there's the bungalow
and everything i didn't have a terrible
um angst about that thank you thank you
very much sir you've made your point
very well uh i'm going to
go first to matt lee and then to uh
hannah dungate who i hope will talk to
the
conservation officers uh exactly what he
meant but first of all to uh matt lee
about highways or what was that highway
sorry yeah go ahead
you're you're muted i'm afraid
after diving a hearing you thought i'd
remember to get it right but i kept
getting wrong in that as well and i
apologize members um
it's been a year now um anyway sorry
about that um i think yet our passover
term is done getting a moment to deal
with a couple of more specific points um
in relation to the sustainability one i
thought was uh prevalent i stepped in
because it is a very interesting point
that's been raised by councillor chana
and i think this might be the first time
we've had it so far in a committee
whether it's south east or any of the
others and that comes to the fact that
where we've lost the five-year land
supply our settlement boundaries have
actually gone and therefore dwellings
that
might have been policy compliant because
they within a settlement boundary are
now uh falling fair of that because
we're only looking at whether or not
they are sustainable um
and
referencing that was it the sun in
anchor is a classic example where
and i think it was allowed
the officers dealt with it sometime last
year and we had a five-year land supply
so as we had the senate boundary the
council's position was any dwelling
inside a second boundary or a proposed
running would automatically be
sustainable because we as an authority
degree agreed the need for dwellings in
the district and we were allowing
windfall within settlement boundaries
what's since happened is because
we no longer have a five-year land
supply our policies around segment
boundaries no longer exist and therefore
each application for dwelling is
assessed on its own merit through the
tilted balance which is sustainability
in the mppf and i'm sure
members that were here three years ago
plus will remember the difficult
conversation we've had similar to this
about
where you know pre applications were
include places where there's already a
large amount of settlement and how comes
previously or relatively recently we've
allowed housing and now we're not and
that is
the difference and it is quite a complex
position because actually an authority
as members as decision makers you could
give the councils
what is now an outdated policy some way
in the determination of an application
and say the thrust that the council has
historically taken is still has merit
but that but once officers are making a
recommendation based solely on the
tilted balance we've come to the
conclusion it's not sustainable and i'm
probably completely confused because
i've tried to
compress about a 20
minute discussion into about two so i
apologize if i've confused you more than
made it easy but
basically we don't have a five-year
landscape anymore and the segment
boundaries have disappeared thank you um
can i now go on to um uh hannah dungate
please to talk on the conservation
matter you're going to clarify something
for councillor china
yes thank you chairman
um
just on the first point that councillor
channel raised in terms of the north of
the site or the north of the road
the north of the site being
north of the rear boundary of the
application site
is undeveloped countryside
north of the building within the site is
the existing
um undergrowth or residential garden um
dense vegetation
to hipsies cottage and also north of the
street is the application site so
hopefully the different norths
clarify that okay thank you that's
helpful
yeah
um also
in terms of the conservation officer
response
he
i don't know if you want me to read that
out verbatim do you want do you want me
to read that
is it going to take a long time how long
is it
can i can i just say that hannah if
anything you only need to concentrate in
a
in a truncated way in the last two
paragraphs oh yeah
speaking
yeah i was gonna say there's it's four
paragraphs but the two final paragraphs
are the most pertinent to the
application if i just read those out
that will help clarify things that's
fine go ahead
this application seeks permission to
construct a house in the garden of
hipste's cottage set back from the
highway so that it aligns with the
bungalows to the east the proposed house
would be similar in scale form and
materials to hipsies cottage
being set back from the highway the
proposal would not obscure any important
views of the listed building but as the
new house would be somewhat taller than
the adjacent bungalows it would would be
in an isolated taller building in this
position noticeably changing the balance
of built form and the visual emphasis
towards the rear of the site and to some
extent fine for attention with the
listed cottage
the existing front head row and railings
provide a pleasantly soft boundary
treatment which complements the setting
of hipsey's cottage the removal of most
of the hedgerow and railings is required
in order to create a parking area for
four cars serving both the existing
cottage and the proposed house this car
dominated frontage would be less
sympathetic to the setting of the
cottage than the current arrangement
in these ways the development would
detract from the setting of the listed
building causing some minor harm to its
significance
to use the terminology of the mppf and
policy d3 of the modern ldp i advise
that the proposal will cause less than
substantial harm to the significant
significance of the heritage asset this
harm must be weighed against the public
benefits of the proposal
the degree of harm in this instance
would be limited irrespective of the
degree of harm paragraph
193 of the mppf requires local planning
authorities to give great weight to the
conservation of a heritage asset when
considering a proposal
in accordance with section 66 1 of the
planning
act 1990 the council must have special
regards the desirability of preserving
the listed building setting due to the
minor harm posed by the proposal the
development poses some conflict with
this duty
for the reasons i have outlined above i
object to the application
it will be down down to the determining
officer or committee to make a balanced
judgment weighing the harm i have
identified against any public benefits
the scheme poses
thank you very much indeed uh hannah i
think that's made it clear i'm going to
go to councillor hull now who's had a
hand up for quite some time been very
patient
oh
thank you very much
um
can you hear me okay yes we can hear you
lovely um
having grown up in steeple um i've been
there you know i know quite a lot of
i've been there all my life um
uh
the residents of steeple all all in
favor of this
um especially the parish council
and they feel that they've been um
they don't get planning permission and
there's no
new houses for young people or
two-bedroomed houses or um anything
that's passed in their village they um
also i do agree with the highways and i
do that is a very bad road
could you is there any way they could
change that so they could
turn the car around all the cars round
in in the garage in the area they have
for parking
uh thank you very much uh uh
councillor
uh can i ask matt lee that if the
committee was minded to approve this is
there a condition or something we could
do to uh
mitigate the the highways concerns or
would it require a new application
uh
see you chairman um call up the location
plan
yes bear with me um while miss dungate's
doing that can i just
expand on something mrs dungate or when
we just talked about the consultation
response um for clarity the mppf when
talking about heritage assets and the
harm only has two criteria's basically
substantial harm
or um
brains complain
less than substantial harm that's the
only two thresholds sorry so substantial
arm is obviously something very
significant and any harm how anything
that's basically anything that's not
substantial falls into less than
substantial harm and therefore
decision makers in this case the
planning committee need to weigh the
public benefits against the harm and
that's what's out in paragraph 196 of
the mppf
and as members will know
personal benefits of an applicant are
normally
given very very limited weight won't
take into account public benefits so
if members are looking to go against
recommendation and need to think about
what public benefits directly
overcome the harm to the listed building
thank you thank you very much yes uh
hard to see what the public benefit
would be but i'm sure somebody may come
up with one uh miss dungate were you
going to show us some something from
highways and mr uh lee you were going to
answer whether it require a new
application to uh mitigate the highways
issue
sorry have you got the car parking one
sorry ms dungate so i wasn't clear i
know i knew i meant yeah this one's
that's it as you can see members from
the plan
the proposal is for two separate tandem
car parking spaces in front of the
property there is no physical way that i
can see that there's a capable of uh
overcoming the conflict with the
highways and
it solely is a case of as you can see
here a property a vehicle would have to
reverse straight back after coming on
and as explained as his tandem so if you
would the front car car at the front and
you needed to move that you'd have to
reverse the first car off before
reversing that one off to then put it
back on so
i can't see any way professionally that
we can overcome that through a condition
thank you thank you very much uh
councillor stamp
uh thank you chair um i actually agree
with a lot of what cancer channel said
and capsular hull um i also listened to
the applicant when he said about them
reversing into the parking spaces
if you go through steeple is a 40 mile
an hour limit on that section of the
road or is it 60 can somebody
well
no disrespect i mean we are dealing with
cars people living houses have cars
we've not gone to electric scooters or
anything yet i actually do have a great
deal of sympathy with the applicant on
here
and also with the parish council they've
made very good points and i've actually
been approached and said there are no
like smaller properties in steeple at
wendy we all have people our youngsters
are moving out there's nothing
like that here so the cat the parish
council is also identified which is what
councillor halls just said
my main issue is and the only thing that
i have got an issue with
is highways and what counselor chan has
said
we would be absolutely
um we'd have to be very careful if we
chose to overturn the officer's
recommendation when highways have
commented even though i have a huge huge
amount of sympathy and i actually don't
mind the house at all i walked walked
along that road myself the other day and
i thought it was and i checked it out
just was i was popping out having a
little around the district and i didn't
see an issue and it is back on near the
bungalows um so um yeah i have a lot of
sympathy mr chairman about this one for
the for the applicant and thank you for
allowing me to speak
thank you uh uh uh
councillor stamp had a mental block
there's obviously been the end of a long
day uh counselor channel you want to
come back if you could keep it brief
please thank you i'll do my best
chairman you know i do like to say a bit
sometimes you do you do
yeah there we go just to get your points
though because it's important isn't it
when we're dealing with people's
applications
you know we should be heard as the ward
member and making representation for our
people and our parish councils
um so yes i have great sympathy as a
parish council and yes it's true
i know the views of the parish they do
want some properties uh two bedrooms as
we do as a council we want to have mixed
properties
and regarding and thank you for reading
out the response because it was clear
then about the conservation with the
word object i've sort of misinterpreted
a bit that paragraph however for me i
think the public benefit is actually
getting a two bed property and um you
know another building into the village
that could be utilized for younger
people or the older persons if those
impressively inhibited moving to that
then that becomes available
and like counselor sample i think i hope
i made it sort of in my initial speech
the real big issue is i'm afraid
the highways
um and i i'm sorry but i i can't
give anything to override that because
it's very rare they do come up with
um an issue where they are against a
development it's quite clear that they
are and i think it would be
irresponsible of myself
if i was not to take that into the
consideration so it's on that
i'm afraid i can't support the
application
thank you very much sir well i thank mr
leafy's very clear explanation now this
sustainability and development boundary
issue because that's made that a bit
clearer as well thank you
thank you councillor bell
thank you um i just wondered if officers
could clarify for me how many bedrooms
hips cottage has please
do we know
um yes through new chair it's also two
bedrooms it is so it would be right so
it would for either way it would free up
a property okay thank you very much for
that thank you thank you councillor
passenger
thank you all right there we are yeah i
would just like to say that i uh i
concur with um with with councillor
chana and uh councillor stamp really i i
have great sympathy for the people of
steeple and i would support this
but
unfortunately you know highways
i've never known them to make a comment
on the whole time i've been here
and i think if they do i
i i just don't know where we would stand
and i'm
unfortunately i'm going to have to uh
um
refuse this on that basis but that basis
alone i'm afraid thank you very much uh
council bastard i'm now going to move a
recommendation that this is refused uh
for the reasons detailed in section b of
the report as it says um do i have a
seconder
i'll second that mr chairman councillor
bell
thank you uh uh i'm going to ask first
of all if this is something that we can
vote by ascent uh or is there or do we
have any dissent uh before i go any
further is there anybody who wouldn't
agree to uh agree that by ascent
and then
okay then therefore asking if you agree
by ascent
agreed reluctantly agreed okay therefore
uh it is regrettably refused because of
the highways uh uh concerned paul's
trying to get in chairman i think cancer
hall is trying to get in
cancer how are you asking speak
no no i was just saying it is about the
highways because if they can do anything
or come back if they can change the cut
you know so the cars can be turned
around yes they could have a job
agreement with it
yeah you can always reapply with a
solution yeah that's right thank you
okay that's great um
so we're now going to item seven any
other items of business that the chair
decides uh urgent and i have none
so i therefore um uh i'm on to item
eight closure of the meeting i thank you
for all your contributions i now draw
the meeting to a close at uh
1918 or 7 18 in english
as the meeting is now closed members are
advised not to enter into any further
discussion on this forum and to please
leave the meeting promptly and thank you
all very much indeed
thank you chairman
thank you good
night everybody
good night good night good night